hey I'm Justin Trudeau and I'm so
excited to be here because I'm in
California with another lizard person
he's a lizard person just like me and
I'm here with him in California which
he's turned into a communist
just like I'm trying to do to Canada
we're both World economic Forum Stooges
but we have really nice
suits look at our suits and look at his
hair I just love him so much oh look at
him look at you I and I'm Gavin Newsom
look at me I smile when I'm talking so
people think I'm a nice guy but actually
I eat babies yes I do I love them
they're delicious and I'm always eating
them and then I use their blood as gel
in my hair it's very exciting for a guy
like me and I'm very happy to be here
with Justin Trudeau who is so evil that
makes me look like a good man yes isn't
it true Justin yes yes it is true yell
it you're just so cute I just love you
so much think about all of the people we
could lock in their homes and freeze
their bank accounts it's very exciting
for both of us I'm so happy about it are
you happy about it gab it's just yeah oh
yeah yeah love it
all right people I'm Dave Rubin this is
the Reuben report it's October 11th 2022
and honestly that might be my life's
work the culmination of everything I
have done everything I intend to do
everything I set out to accomplish in
that little voice over thing and by the
way Connor I want you to confirm this
verbally both of you guys one take
correct one take I did that and I
watched it once and then we just rolled
and it was magic it was just pure magic
uh we have posted that on the YouTube
channel separately so if you would like
to share that with your friends and
family and well-wishers feel free as
always guys we are uh live streaming on
Rumble YouTube and Blaze TV if you have
not subscribed to our Rumble Channel
rumble.com
Reuben report and because it is October
11th this day
was ringing in my head what happened
October 11th a year ago did something
special happened that day well something
very special did happen that day I was
still living in the horrific dystopian
State of California and I'll put some
cash in the jar for saying it uh and I
was invited uh by local La television to
debate famed civil rights lawyer Gloria
Allred about vaccines and lockdowns and
everything else now the ironic part of
course is that she is a famed civil
rights lawyer like she's the people
always say legendary civil rights lawyer
Gloria Allred but she was all about
vaccines and mandates and locking people
down and everything so I was the one
debating the Civil Rights end of it
anyway I showed up this is one year ago
today I show up to the local affiliate I
think it was KTLA if I'm not mistaken in
Los Angeles and I was not allowed in we
were going to do this thing in person I
was not allowed in because I was unvaxed
I was not jabbed and I might have killed
everyone in there even though they were
all vaccinated none of it made any sense
so I said to them look I'm not doing the
show what can I tell you they said okay
if you go home you can do it via Skype
we don't normally do that but you can do
it via Skype you can have the debate so
we did have the debate and I just wanted
to throw back to this one moment because
although the Trudeau knew something
might be my best work this really this
is a top 10 moment for me really are you
a good decent citizen are you vaccinated
it's nobody's business whether I'm
vaccinated that's like me asking you the
last time you got laid I mean it's just
irrelevant all right so you know what's
really relevant is that it's one thing
if you have the right to choose
nor yours is mine
she's the Civil Rights Legend
I'm some YouTube Schmo I mean just
doesn't it it's worth putting that up
again not only because it's kind of
funny but it's just like how insane so
many people went because of covid civil
rights attorneys asking people their
private medical information on live
television to prove that they're good
citizens I mean that is dystopian
socialist lunacy anywho today is a
really really great day every now and
again you wake up in the morning and
these days I'm waking up in the morning
I got one baby in this arm I got another
baby and this arm people are spitting up
all over me there's poop everywhere but
at some point I am able to get to my
phone and the first thing that I saw
this morning is that Tulsi gabbard
Democrat known Democrat Tulsi gabbard
former member of congress former
presidential candidate the last Democrat
remaining in the field before they
officially gave the thing to Biden she
has announced as of this morning that
she is leaving the a Democratic party
this is something I've talked about on
the show often I've had Tulsi on the
show obviously a couple times I consider
Tulsi a friend I sort of have wanted her
to do this for quite some time like what
is left over there I know that she was
as frustrated with the Democrats as I've
been as you've been and she is a
moderate she is a member of our military
an active member of our military by the
way who still goes to training and all
sorts of stuff she's a proud American
she's anti-woke now she may have a
position that's a more liberal when it
comes to abortion than perhaps most of
most of you and and even me perhaps but
she has some sort of moderate position I
don't know exactly what it is but let's
say it's 15 or 20 weeks or something
like that it's a you know something like
that she doesn't believe the state
should do everything she wants the
gender stuff and the neo-racism out of
the schools this is a wonderful moment
right now because we need more
high-profile Democrats leaving and uh I
don't know if you know this guys but
there's an election in about a month a
little less than a month from today and
that's what the theme of the show is
going to be today who are the actual
moderates if you want an America of say
the America of how about 10 years ago
when there was a plurality of opinion
and and you could say things that
weren't fully lined up with your
political party and not be destroyed or
canceled could we just go back to that
well there is one party that's doing
that and I'm going to lay out a freaking
case for you with video tape today there
is a moderate party and there is a
radical party and it's just not the way
the mainstream media would have you
think about it and uh and also it's in
some ways for me it kind of feels like
the things that I've been talking about
here for a long time are finally
bubbling up into the mainstream and and
that is great to some degree it's a
little scary in another way because once
things go mainstream they they kind of
fall flat but that'll be my challenge to
make sure that doesn't happen and that's
what we're doing on the show today so
I'm going to show you a little bit of
tulsi's adios video and then we'll go
from there uh real quick let me talk to
you guys about Cozy Earth I love cozy
Earth uh you know that hotter web hotter
weather used to mean goodbye to a good
night's sleep until I discovered cozy
Earth cozy Earth's bedding is so soft
luxurious and temperature regulating I'm
sleeping better than I have in years
listen there's a good reason why cozy
Earth has thousands of five stars or
five star reviews over at cozyearth.com
it's truly awesome betting here's one
from Laura we literally just got them
put on our new bed yesterday and guys
they are incredible these sheets are
worth every penny cozy Earth sheets made
from a hundred percent viscous from
bamboo are now available in four natural
colors and don't forget their
temperature regulating and very
breathable so you'll sleep cool and
comfy all year round
for a limited time save 35 percent on
cozy Earth bedding be sure to check out
their Ultra Soft loungewear too I love
the sweats even here in Florida go to
cozyearth.com Dave today and save 35 now
all backed up by a hundred night sleep
guarantee cozyearth.com Dave for 35 off
and now back to me okay so this is a
portion of Tulsi gabbards goodbye
Democrats I'm getting the hell out of
here the party is over video that she
posted this morning and then we will
dive in and dissect it when I return I
can no longer remain in today's
Democratic party that's under the
complete control of an elitist cabal of
War mongers who were driven by cowardly
wokeness who divide Us by racializing
every issue and stoking anti-white
racism who actively work to undermine
our god-given freedoms that are
enshrined in our constitution who are
hostile to people of faith and
spirituality who demonize the police but
protect criminals at the expense of
law-abiding Americans who believe in
open borders who weaponize the National
Security State to go after their
political opponents and above all who
are dragging us ever closer to nuclear
war
now I believe in a government that's of
the People by the people and for the
people
unfortunately today's Democratic party
does not instead it stands for a
government that is of by and for the
powerful Elite
now I'm calling on my fellow Common
Sense independent-minded Democrats to
join me in leaving the Democratic Party
if you can no longer stomach the
direction that the so-called woke
Democratic party ideologues are taking
our country
and I invite you to join me
AMA Mia I have been waiting for that for
a long time I am very proud of Tulsi
this is not going to be an easy move for
Tulsi right the machine the mainstream
media the corporate press is going to
try to destroy her the Democrats that
maybe once called her a friend or worked
with her on legislation will now say
she's alt right and all of the worst
things the cancel machine will move on
her all of the stuff but she's doing it
it's a huge risk to whatever she wants
the rest of her career to be she doesn't
know if the Republicans are going to
fully Embrace her I think there's a lot
of evidence that they will despite
differences I don't even know that she
wants to go back into politics but she's
sticking she's drawing a Line in the
Sand I should say and she's saying this
is where I am
and you guys have left if you watch
further into the video she talks about
what happened to the Democrat Party and
how different it is from say when she
became a Democrat 20 years ago to what
it has become now I just want to quickly
go through a few of the things she
talked about the Democrat has the
Democrat Party has fully embraced
wokeness well we certainly know that
they fully invent uh they fully are into
all of this racial nonsense well we
fully know that they are anti-white now
it was interesting she said this one
because this is the one that I see a lot
of people the haters picking up on right
now but it simply is true it simply is
true right if you if you believe in
equity and you believe that we should
help certain people based on their skin
color then you must harm other people so
I think you could argue that the modern
Democrat Party is not only anti-white
it's anti-asian it's anti-jewish it's
anti-any minority white people are not a
minority but it's anti any other
minority they're supposed to be four
minorities right who dare succeed who
dare Buck the trend uh they are
undermining our freedoms they are
against religious people they're
demonizing the police there for open
borders they're weaponizing the security
State all of these things and then she
goes into a couple more and it's all
true it's true all of it as they said in
Star Wars the Force awakens I haven't
mentioned Star Wars in a while
um
so this is good this is really really
good now before I continue on why this
is good I thought we'd show you a video
of Kamala Harris and I believe this is
last night on a late night talk show
Kamala Harris went on the Democrats
could have chosen Tulsi again Tulsi was
the last Democrat who stayed in so
everyone had dropped out already they
had cut or all their backdoor deals for
Pete and everybody else to get into the
administration by backing out before
super Tuesday so the machine could hand
the thing to Biden and Biden's mentally
compromised so they could get him to you
know read poorly off the teleprompter
whatever they wanted him to say but
Tulsi stayed in so she was already an
enemy of the Democrats uh you may
remember that Hillary Clinton also
called her I think she called her a
Russian operative if I'm not mistaken or
a tool of the Russians can I get the
exact quote on that what it was but she
basically said she was a Russian agent
anyway the Democrats could have chosen
they could have said you know what we've
got Biden
he's kind of imperfect and not right but
we know what it is he's breaking down
maybe we could try for something a
little more moderate behind him to kind
of at least give the veneer of
moderation but instead they chose Kamala
Harris Hillary Clinton called Tulsi
while she was running for president as a
Democrat a Russian asset really think
about that that's what Hillary Clinton
did
um
so who did they choose they chose Kamala
Harris well here's Kamala Harris last
night
I mean truly when you you know when you
see our kids and I truly believe that
they are our children they are the
children of our country of our
communities
I I mean our future is really bright if
we if we prioritize them and therefore
prioritize the climate crisis and the
need to address it
the woman says words just to get to the
end of the sentence just meaningless
dribble from a very very vapid human
being so the Democrats had their choice
and I think they are going to rule the
day they decided to destroy Tulsi and
ultimately cause her to leave the party
and instead go with a man who's
obviously mentally compromised for one
reason and a woman who's mentally
compromised for a whole other reason
anyway there is something interesting
happening here because the party that is
supposed to be the intolerant party is
becoming the tolerant party the party
that is thought of as the tolerant party
is becoming the intolerant party you
guys all get it now I'm gonna lay out a
further case of what's going on with
some Republicans right now because first
you can look at Tulsi okay she's leaving
I don't know that she's going to be a
Republican or ever run for office as a
Republican and again I don't know that
she even wants a political future per se
you know in office future but now
there's this new crop of Republicans
guys like JD Vance in Ohio and Blake
Masters in Arizona who's running for
Senate and Carrie Lake in Arizona who is
running for governor Dr Oz certainly not
thought of as a traditional Republican
Herschel Walker former NFL player black
man happens to be black these are all
people who you certainly wouldn't think
are traditional Republicans most of them
maybe were sane or moderate liberals of
a decade or two ago and they're all
waking up and they're they're saying a
lot of the things that are in line with
my political Evolution I think probably
a lot of things that you believe and and
a Playbook that is much more in line
with American values and I think that is
a winner and that's why the machine's
freaking out that's why so many people
are being censored
on big Tech and everything else so now
let's get to it because even on abortion
the Democrats have gone completely
insane and it's now the Republicans who
are moderate more moderate on abortion
so there uh was the Republican uh no
sorry there was the Ohio Senatorial
debate a day or two ago this is JD Vance
the Republican versus Tim Ryan the
Democrat and they went in uh to discuss
abortion as an exception look I've
always believed in reasonable exceptions
this is a misrepresentation of my view
but let's hear it from me not from
Congressman Ryan uh I I absolutely think
the 10 year old girl the case that we've
of course heard a lot about an
incredibly tragic situation I mean look
I've got a nine-year-old baby girl at
home I cannot imagine what's that what
that's like for the girl for her family
God forbid something that like that
would happen I have said repeatedly on
the record that I think that that girl
should be able to get an abortion if she
and her family so choose to do so but
let's talk about that case because why
was a 10 year old girl raped in our
community raped in our state in the
first place the thing the media and
Congress and Ryan they talk about this
all the time the thing they never
mentioned is that poor girl was raped by
an illegal alien somebody that should
have never been in this state in the
first place you voted so many times
against border wall funding so many
times for amnesty Tim if you had done
your job she would have never been raped
in the first place do your job on border
security Don't lecture me about opinions
I don't actually have okay so there's
two things happening there and I want to
show you what the moderate position is
and then we'll get to Tim Ryan's
position in a minute first on the
abortion part now he JD Vance who is
pro-life it is his personal and
religious belief uh in life okay so he
does not want abortion but he does
believe in some exceptions now me
personally you know this and I know this
is against actually what most of my
audience believes but you still tune in
because you're decent people my position
would be that we find a CO we find just
some common ground thing and it's hard
to do and we can talk about whether
that's 12 weeks I think 15 weeks which
is you know now you're into the third
month whatever it might be and then you
know you could maybe go a few weeks past
that that's for every state to figure
out that's what the the beauty of this
experiment is each state can figure out
what it wants to do and then you're
allowed to move according to that so
JD's position is that he he allows for
exceptions okay in the case of rape and
health to the mother Etc so that's
somewhat of a moderate uh position okay
by the way Florida I've often mentioned
this Florida here which is start a
business very red state with a very mean
guy named Rhonda Santos in charge has a
15-week ban on abortion which again is
is basically three and a half months
into a pregnancy and nobody's arguing
about abortion here in Florida like 15
weeks it's like the pro-life people are
like you know what we sort of wish it
was less or didn't exist but
it is what it is we live in America we
we understand there's people different
than us and even the I can't say all of
the the Democrats but even a decent
amount of Democrats here in Florida
acknowledge like the moderate Democrats
because we do have actually some
moderate Democrats here in Florida they
even acknowledge that that's a
compromise so first off so JD he's doing
some level of moderation right on
abortion and then he's also taking the
moderate position when it comes to
immigration which is we have to have a
border that's the moderate position
actually we can figure out all the other
stuff after but a border is a moderate
position countries have borders that's
what makes them countries anyway let's
compare and contrast that with Tim
Ryan's position on abortion my question
was about any limits to abortion at any
point
you know late term anything
look you got to leave it up to the to
the woman because you and I always hear
a bunch of well you and I sitting here
can't account for all of the different
scenarios that a a woman dealing with
the complexities of a pregnancy are
going through how can you and I figure
that out okay so you tell me guys which
is the moderate position that there
should be some exceptions and maybe a
couple weeks or whatever it might be and
we can again hash that out and that
could be decided state by state or that
women should just be able to decide at
eight months or as the baby's head is
coming out uh that you should abort that
baby by the way of course you guys know
that these are the exact same people
exact same people who suddenly want
women to have autonomy over their bodies
but just a year ago they wanted to make
sure that everyone was injected with
things and had to take experimental
medication or would be fired or canceled
and we're going to get rid of nurses and
doctors and everything else so who is
the moderate I think you see it but we
shall continue because one thing that
they always do when it comes off when
when reality is seen and people go wait
a minute those Republicans they're not
as radical as we thought and it's
actually the Democrats that are kind of
going off the deep end what do they do
well they got to scare you they got to
scare you with insurrections and mean
things that happened on that day January
6th find it interesting how preoccupied
you are with this at a time when people
can't afford groceries people can't
afford to walk down the streets safely
let's focus on the significant issues
right now
so as you can see what happened right
before that was that Ryan went all in on
January 6 and Insurrection tried to tie
it to JD blah blah blah and it's like
JD's going that's not really what the
people of Ohio care about and I know
it's not what you guys care about people
are sick of the supply chain stuff
they're sick of the high gas prices
they're sick of the high food prices the
general incompetency of this
Administration so
uh now let's continue because there's
more I'm laying out a case ladles and
jelly spoons uh Blake Masters is running
for Senate in Arizona he is running
against the incumbent Mark Kelly uh and
here is Blake discussing his position on
abortion and again tell me who the
moderate is
it has been noticed that some of these
more strident uh positions were taken
off of your website some say that you
scrub them from your website what's
going on with that I encourage people to
go read my website now it is still the
most pro-life most detailed agenda of
any Senate candidate running Nationwide
I'm pro-life I'm proud to be pro-life I
will never run from that from conception
I'm pro-life is a matter of conscience I
just told you what I believe the law
should be right in Arizona as a voter I
support the 15-week law with all the
exceptions I believe in federal limits I
believe at a certain point everybody of
good conscience knows
five months six months my gosh seven
months that is a baby and we shouldn't
be killing babies for no reason when
they can survive outside the womb and
that's not what his legislation did they
said they were trying to codify Route no
it was so much more extreme than that
they wanted to impose legal abortion
Nationwide
up until the moment of birth and I just
that is way too radical that's not what
arizonans want Common Sense limits
Arizona has said 15 weeks make sense I
think that makes sense okay so who's the
moderate there's Blake Master saying I
have a personal belief he personally is
pro-life but he's saying I am running
for Senate and as Senator I believe that
we could have some kind of compromise on
this this 15-week thing I think that's
the number that we can all sort of go
off right now that sounds like a
somewhat sensible compromise and we can
all have all the discussions about heart
heartbeat and when they feel pain and
when is the exact Genesis of life and
all of those things okay we can have all
that but that is the moderate position
that Blake is taking he's also doing
something very mature which is to say I
have a personal belief right and but
there's a difference between my personal
belief and my public stance not because
I'm lying about it but because I
understand I don't not everybody lives
under my boot Blake continued oh and by
the way he was completely right that
Mark Kelly and the Democrats they have
been pushing for this in essence No
Limit woman could decide whatever she
wanted to do uh based whenever she
wanted to abort this is what they've
been pushing for I can tell you as
someone that has a nine week old
downstairs and a fixed day old
downstairs five day old downstairs uh
that if our surrogate had said to us at
eight months I'm having an abortion I
just feel like having an abortion uh
obviously would have been murder I I
can't it's it's actually like disgusting
to even talk about okay uh Masters
continued to hammer Mark Kelly on the
way he has voted with Joe Biden
basically in lockstep Joe Biden is
spending like a drunken sailor and at
every single opportunity Mark Kelly just
says yes he can't say no to Chuck
Schumer he can't say no to Joe Biden at
least Senator Cinema stopped buildback
better my gosh you were ready to vote
for that that would have just ruined our
economy even worse I know Senator Cinema
caved on the inflation reduction act and
I'm mad at her for that but hey isn't it
interesting that you had to wonder which
way she was going to vote you never have
to wonder which way Senator Kelly is
going to vote because any spending bill
that Biden puts in front of him he will
sign so yeah we got the inflation
reduction act and Mark Kelly was the
deciding vote he hired 87 000 new IRS
agents Mark Kelly voted to send stimulus
checks to illegal aliens he voted to
send stimulus checks to get this violent
felons sitting in jail is that a good
use of taxpayer money I don't think so
think about that the next time you go to
the grocery store and you can't afford
to buy steak or eggs
let me get a quick response to that yeah
yeah that that that's not true which
part well and the the well a lot of it
actually you can do a little Googling
yourself because then it's just a bunch
of nonsense after it's all true he voted
for all of these things right he voted
for absolutely all of these things so
again who is the moderate
I'll allow you to make your decision on
that but let's continue we shall stay in
the great state of Arizona where Carrie
lake is running for governor against
Katie Hobbs uh here's Katie Hobbs uh
talking about her position on Democrat I
should say Katie Hobbs discussing her
position on abortion the Hobbes
administration's weak limit be for
abortion access if it's not 15 weeks
what is it
look abortion is a very personal
decision that belongs between a woman
and her doctor the government and
politicians don't belong in that
decision we need to let doctors perform
the care that they are trained and take
an oath to to perform so if an Arizona
voter were to conclude from your
previous answer that you do not favor
any specific weak limit on abortion
would they be correct
I support leaving the decision between a
woman and her doctor and leaving
politicians entirely out of it
doesn't she come off as an SNL character
like they like dressed her up and put on
fake glasses and I'm pretty sure doctors
taken oath not to do any harm I think
that has something to do with the
hippocratical if you're supposed to help
everybody we can discuss whether
abortion is okay fine you got it uh but
all right so who is the moderate does
that seem like a moderate position that
a woman should just be able to get an
abortion at any point again I say this
is someone that believes you would want
a certain window to allow for abortion
but is that the moderate position or the
radical position and and think about it
this way 20 years ago not even 20 years
ago 12 years ago and perhaps even less
six years ago if a Democrat had said I
believe I believe in No Limits to
abortion they would have been the
outlier in the party but now they are
all repeating the exact same stuff show
me a Democrat who isn't repeating the
exact same nonsense so okay that's her
position you can decide whether it's
radical or moderate for yourself here is
Republic in Cary Lake explaining her
position on abortion I am I'm a woman
I'm a mother I'm all for Women's Health
Care I come from a large family Seven
Sisters I have of course I want Women's
Health Care this has moved Beyond health
care we're not giving women choices I'm
forgiving women true choices and when
they walk into an abortion Center
they're only given one choice and
they're not told that you have the
choice to keep your baby and we can help
and here's how or we can help you find a
loving family who will adopt your baby I
want to give women true choices I will
uphold the Law whatever that law is and
I want to see to it that we save more
lives right now the Democrats have
started pushing so far from that rare
but safe to anything goes up to nine
months of pregnancy after birth Katie
Hobbs my opponent actually is voted for
and you look at her voting record
allowing a baby who survives an abortion
they that the hospital would refuse
Medical Care and allow the baby to die
on a cold metal tray did you catch that
last part this is what they call
post-birth abortions where the the woman
and her doctor could decide ah you know
sure the baby's out of you but there's
this little window to still in essence I
think we usually call that murder that
would be known as murder and again as
someone that just spent a couple days uh
you know in the hospital uh with these
with these preemies and and the babies
all in there and watching that it's just
it's it's just absolutely mind-blowing
uh she also had an interesting line
there
um which was I will uphold the Law
whatever the law is because of course
she's running for governor so she's not
setting the law the law is set by the
legislature but she's saying I will
honor the Law whatever the law is she
has her own again personal belief
um I'm trying to find out if she has any
weak exception on that but she's saying
I want choice in that if a woman is
pregnant instead of automatically
pushing her towards the abortion which
of course we know the Democrats want to
do instead of doing that what she would
like to do is say hey can we help you
perhaps put this baby up for adoption or
we can maybe we can give you you some
resources so you will feel you don't
have to get an abortion and okay I'm
being given some information right now
this is nice to hear uh Carey Lake's
position on this is 15 weeks 15 weeks
that seems to be the magic number that's
according to Rolling Stone and rolling
stone is no friend of the Republicans
and by the way 15 weeks is the current
law in Arizona so who is more radical
the person who wants to keep it at three
and a half months in essence which is
the current law or or the person who
wants to expand it into eight months
I think you got it so Will these two
debate because it seems like they have a
real difference of opinion it might be
nice if they got on a stage together and
talked it out uh well Katie Katie Hobbs
was asked about debating Carrie and she
ain't into it one more time before we
let you go because I think it is on the
mind of Arizona voters are you saying
this morning that there is no
circumstance that you can Envision or
would even try to negotiate in which you
and Kerry Lake would appear at a debate
together before the election
at this point in the race with 30 days
to go our schedule in terms of of forums
is pretty much set and and I'm really
happy with where we are in uh the plans
we have to continue talking directly to
the voters of Arizona guys she just
doesn't have time to have a debate with
her opponent it's such nonsense that
they are afraid to explain their
positions because their positions have
become radical but what's that you say
Dave I want more evidence of this my God
we've got more evidence of it here's
Stacy Abrams from Georgia and Stacey
Abrams no one knows anything about her
accomplishments she's never really done
anything although she did lose a
gubernatorial election in Georgia and
then claimed that the election was
fraudulent repeatedly that's the one
thing we know about her uh well here is
her position on abortion free to become
governor where would you draw the line
15 weeks viability 36 weeks what's the
limit
what I've always said is that abortion
is a medical decision that should be
made by a doctor and the woman and that
the point of viability as determined by
a doctor should always take into
consideration the life and health of a
woman that should be the standard but
the arbitrary standards of timelines
ignore the medical reality that it is a
fallacy we know exactly when a pregnancy
starts that we know exactly where we are
in the system I mean in the in the term
and what doctors will tell you is that
they need to make decisions based on the
woman they are treating and what women
will tell you is that they need the
right to make medical decisions that can
save their lives and save their ability
to control their bodies and their
Futures okay she's just a liar and
ridiculous that we that we have no
knowledge of the science behind any of
this and doctors don't know what they're
doing again as someone with a nine week
old and a five day old and having to do
it through IVF do you know what they do
they take the sperm and then they take
the egg they put them together and quite
literally the next day they can tell you
whether you have have male or female now
I know that the left doesn't believe in
male or female so maybe my doctor is a
complete psychopath although he's one of
the best doctors in the world and people
come from all over the world to visit
him because often couples can't have
kids with it they're heterosexual
couples or homosexual couples or
whatever it might be so he might be a
complete psychopathy although he came
very highly recommended to me but at
that point if you can tell me that they
put the sperm and the Egg together they
put them together and they go boy that's
a that's a male that you got there well
maybe it has a little something to do
with life she also has this crazy
position on on heartbeat that was
exposed a couple weeks ago and much more
but anyway there you go so her position
is do whatever the hell you want that's
basically what it is but let's continue
here's this guy John Federman and he's
up in uh Pennsylvania and he's running
against Dr Oz and he seems like he
should maybe be working at a McDonald's
or something but somehow he's running
for Senate here's his position on
abortion are there any limits on
abortion you would find appropriate I I
don't believe so no I believe that is
between a woman and her physician
I should apologize I didn't mean to put
down people who work at McDonald's this
whatever good people were giving
McDonald's this guy should be just taken
out somewhere you know what I mean like
what is he doing running percent the
guy's wearing a hoodie everywhere like
put on a shirt man
um but okay again whatever the woman
wants to do whatever the woman wants to
do and of course it should not be lost
don't you guys that whatever the woman
wants to do it's the same people who
wanted the woman to be injected even
though they didn't know what she was
being injected with and it turned out
not to work and not to stop the virus
and all that stuff but irony is dead
okay here's Mandela Barnes he's running
for Senate in Wisconsin against Ron
Johnson and uh let's see about his
position on abortion moderate or radical
do you support a woman being allowed to
have an abortion up until birth well
I'll tell you that's a decision that
should be made between a woman and her
doctor I don't have the medical
credentials to make that decision I mean
is that a yes or no though the thing
most members of Congress don't have the
medical credentials to make that
decision a lot of people are going to
say You by not saying yes or no means
that you are open to abortion well my
answer is I'm not a medical professional
and neither are most people who make
this decision I don't have the medical
credentials people program breaking down
medical credentials
again the irony it's just so incredible
uh these people who were forcing people
to be injected with this experimental
thing that turned out not to work did
they have the medical credentials to
force them to do that so again what he's
saying in essence I don't have the
medical credentials kill as many babies
as possible no it doesn't matter eight
months do whatever you want to do lady
because we're all about you we're all
about women that's what they'll tell you
we're all about women but I'm not a math
magician I think about 50 of babies turn
out to be chicks I think right I mean
ballpark Conor's nodding okay pretty
good the point is that most Democrats
are realizing now that the abortion
thing the January 6th thing it's not a
winning campaign that is why Tulsi is
leaving the Democrat Party but will
there be enough of them to fight the
radicals I don't think so and I think
what you what will continue to happen
and this is what I have wanted to happen
this entire time is all of the same
moderates the Libertarians the the the
Liberals mugged by reality they will
find themselves in a wide tent
Republican party and that will be what
America was supposed to be that will be
the place where you can agree to
disagree and we can accept states rights
and we can abide by the rule of law and
more and you're not going to believe
this one we haven't shown this nut bag
in a while Jen musaki who was the White
House Press Secretary a woman who was
paid to lie and I think the misery on
her face often showed that she is now an
MSNBC analyst and it's like well wait a
minute lady how could you get a job
analyzing the news when we know you were
a paid operative for one side but of
course you guys know that's how the
swamp works well she's uh making a point
now Jen saki actually making some sense
uh saying that the Democrats are
disconnected from reality I agree with
Brendan that crime is an issue that
Democrats have to speak to I think there
was a missed opportunity there for
Mandela Barnes when he talked about the
Insurrection I think that was a little
disconnected from what people in
Wisconsin are feeling I mean Milwaukee
crime is up in Milwaukee
you know if Jen saki is now making some
sense that this is like last moments as
the ship is sinking where Jen saki is
the voice of reason within the Democrat
Party but they cannot stop the radicals
they just cannot stop them uh here is
video this is CNN's Dana Bash saying
what we all know to be true the Democrat
leadership is crappy and people are
getting it there is a
um to quote a one-term Democratic
president a malaise that is out there
and that is what our polls have shown in
some of these key States Nevada and
Arizona people just don't feel good
because inflation is high because there
is so much Discord and discontent in
this country and that's a big part of
what you're describing
yeah so CNN is acknowledging it
here it's problems and the president is
in charge right now and he's a well I
don't know that he's in charge but the
president is sitting at the desk and
poorly reading the stuff uh but it's his
party that's in charge right now they
have been leading on all of this stuff
and they have tanked the economy they've
gotten us into this very bizarre war in
Ukraine even though we're technically
not in the war we're just giving people
money and weapons to fight a war we're
in war by the way guys in case you
didn't know and they're probably going
to get that war to go real hot right
before the election that's a sidebar
um the disastrous with withdrawal of
Afghanistan you guys get all the stuff
all the stuff and now Democrat and then
on top of the woke stuff and and the
racialization and the borders and all
the stuff the average person people who
don't care about politics people who
care about politics less than you right
who don't think their politics or
everything they're going well wait a
minute my Town's being overrun if I live
in Texas my border Town's being run
nobody cares but then when a couple
people go up to Martha's Vineyard all
hell breaks loose for 48 hours and they
can get them out of me immediately
people are seeing all the
inconsistencies and the nonsense and now
we're seeing and people have been
waiting for this a long time we are
seeing minorities leave the Democrat
Party which was happening under Trump
right black men moving to the Republican
Party doubled I believe under Trump a
little bit less for black women uh
here's CNN's Tapper Jake Tapper uh
talking to bakari sellers who's a former
South Carolina state representative uh
talking about what's going on with black
men right now
well Laura I can tell you I am very
concerned that the lack of enthusiasm in
our state right now I don't feel and see
the enthusiasm that I think voters
across Georgia should have right now and
I know that oftentimes in midterm
elections people don't turn out to vote
I hope that won't be the case uh this
year in Georgia she's talking about
Democratic voters yeah no and I mean I
think she's sounding the alarm just as
many people have been doing but it ain't
just Atlanta I mean it's Philadelphia in
the race in Pennsylvania uh it's
Cleveland in the race uh with Tim Ryan
and JD Vance it's Orlando in Miami and
and uh Val demmings race and so
Democrats have to do a better job
particularly and I can't wait for my
phone to blow up after I say this but
particularly with black men
they just can't come to black men on a
after Labor Day and say come vote for us
every two years there has to be a more
direct engaged approach with black male
voters who to by all intents and
purposes after African-American women
are the second largest turnout base and
that's just something that we haven't
done forever and it drives me crazy
call me crazy guys but I think that uh
black people are just like white people
I think white people are just like Asian
people I think Asian people are just
like Indian people from an American
context I think people like Law and
Order I don't think people like feeling
like if you're going to go on the subway
or walk down the street you're going to
be mugged or shot or pushed into a
subway car or whatever it might be I
think people are looking at it
regardless of their skin color and going
hmm Democrats wanted to defund the
police well look what happened in New
York City under that Democrats want
illegal immigration in sanctuary cities
well look what happened to this city
under that and I think people are
realizing it and I think they're
realizing it real fast and I don't think
the Democrats have anything left they
will have some sort of surprise because
they're evil but I don't think they have
anything left when it comes to sane
policy and if you really want to see how
insane this thing is getting well
Saturday Night Live which was a comedy
show on NBC uh for decades it used to be
a comedy show nobody watches it now it's
completely irrelevant it's ridiculous
it's partisan it's hacking and
everything else well even they are now
going after bite and I'm going to show
you it's about a 45 second clip here
it's not funny I I just want to warn you
you're not going to laugh you're going
to get the joke you're not going to
laugh the can laughed at the whole thing
but even they are now going after Joe
Biden this week President Biden pardoned
thousands of convicted marijuana users
and it feels like maybe he celebrated
with him a little because yesterday
Biden gave a speech at a car factory and
opened with this
let me start off with two herbs
made in America
spawn with two words Jesus H Christ
has then heard criticizing reporters at
the White House for shouting questions
at him questions like what year is it
and who's the current president
also they weren't reporters they were
doctors
all right whatever they got about 40
writers that put this thing together I
got these two schmotes no offense guys
um so that's Saturday Night Live but it
continues schmoes do people say schmoes
anymore
[Music]
Hawk that's what Larry David says uh
anyway here is uh I believe he's ESC
still with ESPN ESPN went so woke he is
still with ESPN I wasn't sure uh Stephen
A Smith who's been really for the last I
don't know about 20 years or so like one
of the most influential sports
broadcasters in America uh who is by no
means he happens to be black big damn
whoop uh by no means a standard
Republican well he went on Jesse Waters
show on Fox talking about how out of
control the Democrats are what is the
Stephen A Smith platform to solve the
crime and homelessness crisis well first
of all I did not know you dropped this
on me I certainly didn't know we were
going to be talking about this but I'm
game four thank you so much for having
me there is no question that a lot of
these issues need to be addressed there
is no question that we should be against
an extremely Progressive agenda that's
calling for people to be released from
prison on multiple occasions that's
ignoring a lot of crime that's taking
place in the streets there is no doubt
about that where I don't vibe with you
Jesse Waters who I respect is that when
you talk about politicians themselves
being innocent they're not innocent in
all of this a matter of fact in some
instances the division that exists and
has existed for so long has contributed
to kind of some of the nonsense that's
been taking place in the streets it
doesn't excuse it doesn't mean it
doesn't have to be addressed where do we
disagree I feel like we're in agreement
on everything okay what I'm just saying
you said earlier in your in your great
monologue okay kind of politicians or
themselves were like innocent for
Chronicles and I didn't say that I said
they're acting like they're the victims
when you call them out for not doing
okay well some of them well actually a
lot of them deserve the criticism that
they're getting there is no doubt about
them La I was in L.A the homeless
homelessness that exists there I got an
issue with that certainly when you look
at Gavin Newsom and some of the policies
that he's put forth you're talking about
you're talking about a lot of different
things that need to be addressed I don't
agree with everything and I'm not about
to pretend that I do are there some
people that when they're talking just
because of the way they talk talk I'm
Stephen A Smith and thank you for having
me on the show and I'm going to tell you
all the stuff that you kind of want to
listen to them it's interesting because
this is a sports guy I've liked him from
a sports angle for a long time right uh
but now he's sort of in these culture
wars and basically saying hey all this
crime nonsense the homeless nonsense uh
we're starting to put it together and it
has a little something to do with
democrat-run cities so Dave how are you
going to tie this whole thing together
well there is a way out of this and the
way out is by honestly assessing what's
going on here I think that's what we've
done for the last 40 minutes the way out
is good people just saying sorry
Democrats adios goodbye we can still
fight for moderate positions you don't
have to be a republican what do I always
say you don't have to be a republican
but you cannot be a Democrat so we will
see where Tulsi ends up on that Spectrum
but there will be one party
that will be wide-ranging and it will
have some religious people who may not
be thrilled with the more libertarian
people but hopefully under the broad
umbrella of freedom and americanism
people will realize how special this
thing is well not realize they will
remember and reinvigorate how special
this thing is and we will fix it I
really think we can and how do we do it
we do it by conversation with which is
exactly what I did with Bill Maher just
last week the bottom line is the fact
that you and I are have these
differences and don't it's like it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter
predictably within the parameter yes of
two human beings the odd the odds the
two human beings would see everything
exactly the same way how pathetic and
annoying and ridiculous yeah and
ridiculous so the fact that you know we
both fall within the 30 yards
how could you expect more than that or
even care that it's not more than that
or not love the person
I
I hear you brother that's all like
that's all I can say about that I hear
you brother what I would like to do more
than anything else honestly I'd like to
shoot hoopsy at some point I I can't
tell you how I don't care about I don't
care that I don't mean that I don't care
about the differences I know you don't
either I've said this before on this
podcast I'm going to say it again since
this whole thing started can I take off
my shoes now already because then I'd
feel really at home killing it with guys
I am so many guy friends yeah that I
didn't have before and I'm glad you're
one of them because uh this was super
fun but it's over now that's it
now I got it oh sorry Bill I have to get
on a plane and ring the bell
[Laughter]
that's how we do it guys that's how we
do it it's not that politics doesn't
matter of course it matters why do I put
on this jacket and spray my hair every
day it's because these things do matter
but I I am pretty sure if you're
watching this show you actually do want
to live with in a country with some
people who think about things a little
bit differently and as Bill said you
know if we've got this 30 difference on
some of these things it's like there's
there is room in this country for all of
us that fit within that right within
that like let's say that lane of like
yeah we're all going to be a little bit
different it's cool so let's fight the
authoritarians let's fight the elitists
let's fight the new racists and the
walksters and then let's see what's on
the other side it will be fun man
imagine if we could do it I really think
we can do it I'm feeling it right now
like if we can get to the other side and
we and we will all look back and go boy
remember that woke nonsense remember
when they were chopping off kids
genitals and remember when they
it's nuts like we live in the Middle
Ages like but if we actually got to the
other side and the squad was a distant
memory
and Biden and all of this was just a
distant memory and we just had a sane
functioning president say Ron DeSantis
and a government that was scaled back a
little bit and if you wanted to smoke
weed you could and if you didn't want it
you didn't have to and if you wanted to
marry a dude and you happen to be a dude
you could and you weren't going to force
other people to marry dudes it can all
work it's what we had it's what we had
it's what the promise of America is I
think we can do it uh we got a great
cold close for you to really wrap this
thing all together let me get to a
couple reubenreport.locals.com comments
then we're good uh EK says calling
Kamala vapid is an insult to the word
vapid I do need more vapid like words
can we get some synonyms for vapid and
we'll use them in the future
um weekly cigar says Hobbes sounds like
a horrible cartoon character that's what
I'm saying it's like she comes off as an
SNL character like they took an actress
and they put her in the thick Rim
glasses and they gave her the straight
blonde hair and they just put her out
there this thing about not debating your
opponent like we have 30 days left I
don't have time it's like all she's
going to be doing is raising money how
about stand up there and defend your
ideas you're not you're not a legit
candidate in my view if you're not
willing to debate your opponent one time
stand on a stage for two hours in that
seriously controlled environment if
you're afraid of that I don't see how
anyone in Arizona could vote for her
Tony says It's amazing when you listen
to Republicans versus Democrats
Republicans give positions Democrats
Dodge questions
look it just is it just is now this is a
very odd thing if you would have told me
seven years ago this is the the position
that I would be in
and I would be celebrating someone like
Tulsi gabbard leaving the Democrat Party
because I did it before her and I'd live
in Florida and all of this stuff it
would be quite bizarre but here we are
so reality is what it is the the world
is what it is whether you would like it
to be or not what you can maybe do is
push it a little bit on the margins and
I think if we do that I'm telling you
something really good can happen in
about a month on these midterms and we
can move past this thing and and wrap it
up I'll go do something else what do you
guys want to do if we fix the whole
thing you guys want to go into some
other kind of business together maybe we
could uh what do you want to do finger
painting you want Phoenix was to finger
paint what do you want to do that was an
odd one that was odd you want to maybe I
don't know we could sell hot dogs or
sell hot dogs all right there you go uh
guys reminder uh like subscribe to our
videos rumble.com Ruben report
reubenreport.com
reubenreport.locals.com part one of my
interview with Megan Kelly is up on
platforms right now and of course the
whole thing is up at
reubenreport.locals.com and we leave you
with the woman they chose instead of
Tulsi God help us all
with the plan
uppercase t uppercase p d plan do you
plan to visit the Border
uh um not today but
um I have before and I'm sure I will
again I said I'm gonna go to the border
and when are you going to the Border
vice president Administration has asked
been to the border so this whole this
whole this whole thing about the Border
you haven't been to the Border
uh and I haven't been to Europe and I
mean I don't I don't understand the
point that you're making and I'm being
clear with you right now yes okay and
and so if you're interested I'll
continue to be clear there are a whole
lot of people especially people who live
in rural communities who don't there's
no Kinkos there's no Office Max near
them it is time for us to do what we
have been doing and that time is every
day we are doing it but should we have
done it soon we are doing it what do you
see as the biggest National Security
challenge confronting the U.S what is
the thing that worries you and keeps you
up at night
frankly one of them is our democracy you
don't feel misused or underused
no I don't when folks
before I went off script a little bit